bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de c'est une culture et
tout de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi
14 février des annales et délaisser les
tapis de taekwondo pour un appareil
photo l'artiste guillon comtois a capté
les athlètes de sa ville la commune il
expose jusqu'au samedi 24 mars et le
festival de bd revient depuis le 7
février les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines invite au pays
du manga ateliers jeux projection nous
ferons le point sur la programmation
mademoiselle k est un des visages du
rock féminin français l'artiste propose
des textes intense elle se produit le 6
avril prochain sur la scène de la
batterie de guyancourt art capital c'est
près de 2000 artistes qui exposent des
artistes venus de toute la france et de
l'internationale des talents reconnus ou
en devenir et parmi eux un événement
jean-claude l'ouvrier un peintre bucquoy
il présente cette année un portrait
celui de dorine bourneton premières
femmes pilotes handicapés
un tableau né d'une rencontre en 2016 et
il était l'invité de grégory canal et
dans le 7-8 journal du mardi 13 février
j'ai discuté avec elle et puis on est
plein de choses en commun entre autres
le défi et puis spontanément je lui dis
bah écoute dorine ça dis pas que je
t'explose en 2018 au grand palais jeudi
je sais pas si j'y arriverais mais on
peut toujours essayer il sportives comme
sam paraplégique ça chante le handicap
c'est
c'est vraiment très difficile de se
déplacer beaucoup de choses qui sont
difficiles pour eux quoi j'ai revu un
atelier à d'autres personnes de suivre
au mieux ce grand la voie oui la ville
de guyancourt propose à partir de samedi
17 février une exposition à l'hôtel de
ville
des photographies de fameux guyancourt
toiser l'auteur de ces clichés est avec
nous en plateau des ânes
enfin vous êtes accompagné de bénédicte
alliés qu in adjointe au maire en charge
de la culture aux formes dont soir alors
là les femmes sont capturées par votre
objectif ce sont des sportifs
oui des sportives qu'on a dû choisir
avec l'équipe culturelle la ville m'a
chargé en fait de faire une exposition
sur l'art le mouvement le sport les
femmes
donc il a fallu à rencontrer toutes les
sportives qui ont bien voulu participer
au projet et du coup on a essayé de les
photographier je sais pas si
l'exposition va être pas être bien mais
en tout cas j'essaie de faire de mon
mieux et photographié le sport c'est une
manière pour vous peut-être de rester
dans un an dans votre univers vous
attendent ancien champ du taekwondo
alors pas du tout alors le sport c'est
pas du tout mon domaine dans la
photographie
mais après du coup j'ai laissé parler
l'inspiration c'est vrai que j'ai été
découverte par rapport à un concours et
suite à ce concours où ils m'ont ils
m'ont proposé un peu ce projet dans le
milieu du sport
effectivement avec mon background dans
le sport via le taekwondo donc c'est
vrai qu'il y avait des similitudes dans
mon capter les capter les mouvements
mais ce n'était pas quelque chose que je
savais faire
on va dire j'avais pas une expertise
dans la photographie sportive et ses
fameuses a pu les rencontrer vous l'avez
dit grâce à la ville bénédicte alico in
ses photographies elles entrent
notamment dans le cadre du temps des
femmes c'est un temps à ne pas rater à
guyancourt et internet pas rater en
effet l'égalité hommes femmes a toujours
été une préoccupation importante sur lui
en cours une préoccupation bien sûr
quotidienne mais au moins de mars
c'est un petit peu avant
on fait vraiment un focus sur ce sont
des femmes et donc des ânes intervient
pour ce temps des femmes sur cette
exposition qui lui a été commandé et en
effet on a mis on l'a mis en contact
avec les associations sportives
c'était important de montrer que dans
certains sports les femmes ont aussi
leur place
et puis aussi que le corps de la femme
qui peut parfois être maltraités
souffrir est aussi d'une belle force est
quelque chose de beau parent son
objectif
les femmes le corps et le mouvement vous
photographiez il ya ce mouvement
pourtant elles sont en sont où sur un
départ de course
comment vous les prenez fait
photographier alors j'ai essayé de
rentrer à chaque fois dans la dynamique
dans la thématique de chaque sport de
trouver vraiment le mouvement
l'amplitude
au début ça n'a pas été simple il a
fallu laisser du temps aux sportives
déjà elle avait un peu de pression
il faut pas le cacher de se faire
photographier donc je leur ai laissé du
temps et puis j'ai trouvé le pour moi le
bon moment en fait de les photographier
donc il a fallu répéter répéter ce sont
des photos posées ou des photos prises
sur l'instant les deux les deux sur
certaines des photos qui sont par
exemple sur la scène céder certaines
photos ou fatalisme en statique ça a été
posée et puis celles qui sont en
mouvement forcément ce soit sur le sur
le vif
donc là il a fallu répéter et répéter
des fois jusqu'à épuisement pour
certaines nos sportives
malheureusement mais c'était
principalement temps dans le vif de
l'action un travail au long cours et
vous êtes beaucoup de noir et blanc
c'est une volonté c'est peut-être le
moment propice à chaque fois alors
choisi cesse j'ai pris le noir et blanc
pour une bonne partie des photos parce
qu'on est dans le cadre d'une exposition
le noir et blanc ça évoque beaucoup de
choses à beaucoup de personnes je les ai
plutôt concentrer vraiment sur les
parties où on a fait les clichés à la
ferme du bel ébat là on est sur la scène
donc je me suis dit voilà beaucoup de
contrastes beaucoup de noir et blanc
beaucoup de lumière valait mieux les
passait en
alors les et les athlètes sont lus en
courtoisie vous l'êtes vous même
bénédicte hélico in la commune m
régulièrement mettre en avant les
artistes locaux alors ça dépasse souvent
guyancourt mais c'est une volonté de la
commune est vrai que depuis trois ans on
a un concours qui s'appelle par talent
qui est donc à la grande salle
d'exposition et des ânes a été découvert
l'a donc en effet ça permet ce concours
a déniché bas des nouveaux artistes des
artistes locaux bien sûr parce que c'est
ouvert aux artistes locaux et aux
artistes du territoire mais en effet ça
a permis d'ouvrir et de permettre à des
artistes locaux d'exposer principalement
à la mezzanine léman ou es ce que vous
avez deux lieux d'exposition et à la
mezzanine et la salle d'exposition est
justement en ce moment il ya une autre
exposition à l'or en part chez les plus
jeunes cette fois vous exposer des
doudous en effet alors la mezzanine est
plutôt comme vous l'avez dit pour les
artistes locaux mais la salle
d'exposition permet d'avoir des grandes
expositions thématiques et je crois que
elle a un grand succès mais la
participation des habitants est très
importante pour nous et comme on le voit
pour des ânes
on le voit aussi à doudou bien sûr les
artistes sont choisis et mais il ya
aussi énormément de participation
notamment avec les ateliers par le
dessin oui avec le décès de les deux
mascottes
malgré les ratios en effet une
récupération au niveau des habitants
c'est vrai que c'est important parce que
pour nous c'est important que ce soit en
direction de tous les publics et même
les publics qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
venir
donc cette expo de douai taxer si
vraiment à tout le monde et c'est
vraiment un plaisir et je c'est vrai que
je remercierai mais je pense que des
années aussi d'accord avec moi l'équipe
parce que l'équipe des niches déjà
dirigé deux nouveaux talents mais elle
aussi à la campagne et je pense qu'elle
va vraiment vers les habitants et notre
objectif c'est d'aller vraiment les vers
les habitants aussi alors justement ce
nouveau talent votre nom des ânes
l'exposition débute le samedi 17 février
elle a le courage jusqu'au 24 mars et
les doudous ça se termine un tout petit
peu plus tôt non-profit on peut en
profiter pendant les vacances parce que
c'est jusqu'au 4 mars
merci tous les deux d'être venu en
plateau avec votre actualité
on va parler d'une autre exposition
cette part aux clayes-sous-bois benjamin
flao est qualifié comme l'un des
dessinateurs les plus talentueux de sa
génération il dessine depuis enfants son
oncle dit de lui qu'il est un homme
crayon ils exposent à l'espace philippe
noiret rencontre naïm en feu l'un et
gunther marge en hollande et les deux
personnages principaux de benjamin flao
l'artiste fait de la bande dessinée
inspirée de souvenirs de voyage
donc que j'ai fait à partir de d'un
voyage que j'avais fait mais plusieurs
voyages que j'avais fait en afrique de
l'est qui au départ était sous forme de
jeu là le matériau que j'avais c'était
c'était plutôt des carnets de voyage des
carnets
les dessins et puis ddt petites notes et
j'ai transformé en
que j'ai transformée en
récit en fiction et finalement ça a
donné un diptyque avec tous les
ingrédients que j'ai pu piocher pour ces
voyageurs
[Musique]
l'afrique est la mer pour ce nantais de
naissance le grand bleu est une source
d'inspiration
jusqu'à ces
frappant danser dans sept pays d'afrique
c'est que il ya des choses qui sont
restés immuables
en tout cas des choses qu'on existait
encore chez nous il ya cent ans qui ont
disparu qui ont cours trouvent dans les
musées et chez eux c'est encore bien
vivant on s'est pas vraiment c'est pas
vraiment un garage s'est pas vraiment
mais un peu de bazar mais il ya des
choses qu'on voit pas trop bien voilà
mes rêves sont un peu fait de deux ça
benjamin flao dessine depuis l'enfance
histoire vraie se mêlent les rêves et
une vie à double facette
moi j'ai un peu de 2,2 vista dire que
j'ai une vie qui se passe à l'extérieur
où par exemple kim qui me fait voyager
qui me permette d'aller promener donc en
afrique par exemple puis genesi
intérieur qui par exemple mes rêves
alors là je parle de l'aspect graphique
surtout parce qu'il s'agit d'une expo de
dessins
voyageur au long cours les placards de
ses dessins sur des murs de temps d'une
exposition
avant de repartir vers de nouveaux rêves
nous décollons maintenant pour le japon
avec camille lambert le pays du soleil
levant est mis à l'honneur à saint
quentin en yvelines avec la nouvelle
édition du festival de bd ball sky et
oui deuxième édition plus exactement qui
se tient jusqu'au 4 mars dans toutes les
médiathèques du réseau de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
programmation se révèle riche et varié
contes projections de films jeux
animations et manga y en a pour tous les
goûts et pour tous les âges
deux expositions sont aussi installées
l'une à la médiathèque du canal c'est
bubble stick qu'on voit sur ces images
l'autre est à la médiathèque
saint-exupéry julien au mess
responsables du festival nous en dit
plus sur ces expositions
pour ce qui est des blue bulls tic en
fait c'est un travail qui a fait la
médiathèque du canal avec le
conservatoire de montigny et céder des
stickers faits par les enfants qui vont
être collé un petit peu dans toute la
médiathèque
et pour ce qui est de
l'autre l'exposition qui au nom puisque
c'est la maison d'édition crown qui nous
la fournit ça va tourner sur deux mangas
donc justement un manga pour les jeunes
plutôt my rock cadet bien qu'un manga
qui a été un des cartons l'année
dernière est un manga seinen sur les
chercheurs sur les chercheurs d'or qui
s'appelle et les mangas dont parle
julien omnes vous pouvez en voir
quelques images à l'écran dans chaque
lieu d'exposition ont été installés des
mangas qui sa prochaine au japon c'est
un lieu entre le cybercafé et la
bibliothèque où chacun peut venir lire
des mangas en libre service
le principe a été repris et installés
dans les deux médiathèques de saint
quentin en yvelines
et il ya aussi des ateliers cette faille
des professionnels oui avec le mangaka
you chimiques à tyra dessinateur de
manga prochain atelier prévu ce samedi à
elancourt et mardi à plaisir et aux
clayes-sous-bois il vous apprendra à
perfectionner votre technique ou tout
simplement découvrir le dessin manga est
alors pour ceux qui est comme moi sont
pas très doués avec un crayon ou pour
les cinéphiles et des projections
oui effectivement on ya pensé avec du
miyazaki notamment difficile de passer à
côté de ce réalisateur quand on évoque
le japon pour rappel c'est lui qui a
réalisé les très connus princesse
mononoké le voyage de chihiro
c'est aussi le co-fondateur du studio
ghibli le 24 février sera diffusé le non
moins connu porco rosso au grenier à sel
de trappes
le film se passe dans
l'entre-deux-guerres et raconte
l'histoire de marco un pilote qui vient
secourir les personnes en difficulté à
bord de son hydravion rouge on regarde
un extrait de la bande annonce
nous ferons temps d
mais il ya aussi un autre film culte
akira au grenier à sel de trappes
c'est un film d'animation réalisé par
katsuhiro otomo adapté du manga du même
nom lui il est projeté au grenier à sel
de trappes le 24 février à 20 heures il
est sorti en 1988
l'intrigué se passe après la troisième
guerre mondiale dans un neo tokyo
apocalytique un jeune garçon est capturé
par l'armée et fait l'objet
d'expériences scientifiques
il est par la suite mêlée à la légende
d'akira un sauveur qui serait doté d'une
grande puissance
le film est considéré comme un classique
du genre
[Musique]
à qui la
pour les ateliers ou pour les films
pensez à vous inscrire tous les
renseignements sont disponibles sur le
site internet cd médiathèque de saint
quentin en yvelines
merci kamini alors un mois pour voyager
sans quitter l'agglomération est quoi
exactement est beau gosse cali est en
fait aussi le sujet de notre coup de
coeur cinéma
[Musique]
cette semaine le rendez vous du 7e art
c'est marilyn coup de l'espace philippe
noiret des clayes-sous-bois qui nous qui
nous le donne et on l'écouté
le coup de coeur de l'espace philippe
noiret cette semaine c'est notre
participation au festival bébel sky avec
la thématique du manga donc on vous
propose deux films un pour les plus
grands le garçon et la bête donc à
partir de 10 ans donc un animé japonais
de mamoru hosoda qui est également le
réalisateur des enfants nous quand vous
conseillera sur la suite deuxième
semaine des vacances donc le garçon et
la bête ces lignes c'est l'histoire d'un
double apprentissage dans un monde
divisé donc en deux catégories les bêtes
et les humains et ça va être la
rencontre d'un jeune garçon qui est
perdu dans le monde des bêtes
il va rencontrer son disciple le
deuxième film quand vous propose donc un
autre animé qui est panda petit panda
pour les plus petits cette fois à partir
de 2-3 ans qui est neuf de jeunesse de
miyazaki et takahata
donc c'est une petite fille qui va se
retrouver seul et qui rentre dans sa
maison et qui découvre un bébé panda et
papa panda voilà donc ça va être un film
qui propose deux courts métrages donc
sur panda petit panda
vous pouvez retrouver nos horaires sur
le site internet
quatre acteurs qui viennent à votre
rencontre l'équipe de lâcheté de famille
le dernier long métrage de dany boon
sera à l'ugc skyways ce samedi 7 février
à 20h30
on regarde un extrait allez donc c'est
pas tes oignons est d'aller vers l'autre
produit quand paris 1
d'ailleurs il n'était pas du tout prévu
qu'il se revoit dans un bien maman
heureusement la vie est bien faite
[Musique]
tu m'as tellement chez panini chez
l'autre
bonjour madame et on continue c'est
cette culture en parlant musique
initialement prévue le 9 février dernier
le concert de mademoiselle k a dû être
reporté à cause des conditions
climatiques de la semaine précédente
mais l'artiste vous donne rendez vous le
6 avril prochain entretien réalisé avec
nicolas landry mademoiselle kaas ou les
brûlures l'incandescence intacte un
nouvel album qui vous a fait du bien
ouais je n'attendais pas c'est un
premier quelques sites web un oui mais
je vais le dire à la musique fait du
bien en général c'est recommandé c'est
pas remboursés mais assez fortement
recourbé justement cet album il vient
d'où ce qui auparavant vous parler
d'amour d'infidélité et cette fois ça de
plein de coeur c'est marrant je sais pas
d'où ça vient c'est le truc sur
l'infidélité parce que j'ai jamais fait
de chansons là dessus ou alors j'ai un
gros trou dans ma tête mais je sais pas
voilà donc donc non en fait j'ai pas
spécialement parlé d'infidélité par
contre c'est vrai que là la relation de
couple à relation à devait la réaction
que les autres m'intéresse beaucoup
et non ce qui est nouveau dans cet album
c'est juste que c'est complètement
obsédé par la rupture et du coup c'est
que c'est vraiment le tout le fil rouge
de l'album c'est la rupture à part une
chanson un peu à part qui s'appelle j'ai
pleuré qui parle plus d'eux
de l'amour et de la mort des êtres
proches et de notre rapport à eux
au delà de la mort et puis aussi de la
tristesse mais tous les albums est
vraiment axé sur la rupture et samaâ
permet du coup aussi de ne pas trop me
stresser sur le style des morceaux que
j'allais faire serrer des moyens des
morceaux électro il ya des morceaux plus
il ya m'a justement j'ai pleuré qui est
très folk il ya des morceaux aussi plus
rock tout simplement
et aussi des morceaux en anglais des
morceaux en français parce que ça
faisait partie de cette histoire et est
en fait c'était pas un problème moi
c'était du moment qu'il y avait ce cette
cohérence plus de rendre le propos est
dans et dans la douce aviez en fait ce
sont les origines spi rations à vouloir
de cette rupture ça vous a concerné vous
vous êtes rapprocher de votre entourage
peut être si pour certains ce qu'ils y
ont ressenti
ah ouais alors ça c'est dans la chanson
pour aller mieux
c'est pas spécialement axée sur pour le
coup sûr la rupture c'est plus bas c'est
cette question que j'ai posée a pas que
moi d'abord j'ai commencé par mon
entourage
après j'ai élargi et des gens dans la
rue le cordonnier g km
mais qu'ils tiennent leurs aveux de chez
moi fin voilà des gens que je trouve
sympa où j'ai croisé que je trouvais
sympa et qui j'ai envie de poser la
question c'était plus à brève ou alors
qu'est-ce que vous quand vous être ici
vous n'êtes pas bien qu'est ce que vous
faites pour aller mieux et je trouvais
ça cool de deux d'avoir le plus de
réponses possibles et et puis ce que
j'aime bien c'est qu'il ya aussi tout et
son contraire il ya des gens qui disent
surtout je m'isole pas et de toutes les
misères et c'est aussi ça la réponse
c'est que c'est que les réponses dans la
vie sont pleines antagonismes se
trouvent etc etc dans l'antagonisme
probablement que se trouve là la vérité
ou pas mais ce que j'aime bien c'est en
fait c'est l'état d'esprit de ce morceau
puisque c'est c'est surtout de manière
plus globale
c'est ce qui se dégage qui est assez
bienveillant et parce que j'ai demandé
aux gens au fond de me donner le de me
parler du meilleur d'eux en fait ils
personnes personne n'a jamais dit
quelque chose de pas de méchant mais
deux en fin de
et puis a pas de mauvaises réponses
surtout créé parce que tout le monde a
cherché le meilleur de ce soir pour
aller mieux parce qu'en général on
cherche son meilleur pour aller mieux et
c'est ça que je trouvais intéressant et
qui fait du bien je trouve quand je
réécoute ou morceaux justement l'album
en entier alors ça peut se faire qu'en
jésus nous a fait du bien
ouais c'est pas de cinquième album oui
c'est toujours vous mademoiselle k dans
toutes les chansons via de vous ouais
ouais mais bon et bien sûr non mais
c'est enfin je pense qu'on a on finit on
ne cesse jamais de chercher
de toute façon est de chercher qui en
est et heureusement parce qu'en fait je
pense qu'à chaque chaque chose
importante qui nous arrive dans la vie à
chaque événement c'est une occasion de
se découvrir un peu plus aussi ou alors
de découvrir des choses qu'on ne
connaissait pas de soi etc
mais c'est vrai que oui c'est vrai que
c'est mon identité et que ça je pense
que en tout cas quand je fais des
chansons je sais ce que je veux jusqu'à
un certain point et puis après la magie
c'est à tiens j'avais jamais exploré ça
allons-y
vous avez mentionné l'électro on en
trouve de plus en plus dans vos dans vos
morceaux vous allez recherche pour ses
cd contenant des dictionnaires religieux
auprès d'artistes peut-être dans votre
entourage web à l'asticot web à
l'ajustement en face avait longtemps que
je leur avais d'électro mais je savais
que j'y arriverai pas tout seul
parce qu'enfin déjà ce que j'ai un petit
côté flemmarder en plus non plus
sérieusement parce que je pense est
important les rencontres pas déjà fait
un mois que je passe déjà pas mal de
temps seul pour tout ce qui est écriture
des textes mêmes
je pense que l'écriture pour le coup de
textes vraiment quelque chose qui est de
soi avec soi même et voilà autant le
moment où dans quel moment aussi où je
compose je prends ma guitare puis marion
je m'ennuie en fait tout simplement et
j'ai vraiment besoin de jouer avec
d'autres gens et ça parce qu'il ya
vraiment cet aspect ludique aussi que
dont j'avais beaucoup besoin aussi dans
la musique et est donc j'ai rencontré ce
musicien
enfin donc dont je suis père admiratif
ça peut être jérémy poirier qui nous
tuait un projet lui qui s'appelle
setting coco et qui est un projet
électro et c'est un mec moi il vient du
classique
d'ailleurs il est il à chaud qu'il a
fait là la maîtrise de versailles il a
beaucoup fait de chants classiques et de
flûte traversière si c'est un magnifique
foutiste et là sur l'album rien à voir
il maîtrise hyper bien tout ce qui est
sainte et tout ce qui est pro d'électro
justement est donc à pas mal des
morceaux tellement qu'on a qu'on a fait
ensemble qu'il a produit et voir
même incompréhension et surya mener plus
tard à mettre encore plus électro 12
albums mais je pense que c'est le début
certainement de
oui c'est une couleur qui me plaît
beaucoup c'est aussi enfin
ce que j'aime bien c'est moi y'a électro
électro pense à dire c'est justement
comment faire d'électro en étant
en étant un ayant sa personnalité et son
truc pour moi c'est ça la réalité parce
que j'ai entendu des gens n'écoutent pas
mal déjà et puis après il ya electro
chanson électro instrumental c'est pas
du tout il ya tellement de courant
différent et de couleurs différentes et
ce qui est sûr c'est que je sais pas par
exemple j'écoutais ya pas longtemps à
chet baker avec yum ce qu'ils avaient
fait ensemble et j'adore ça et par
contre je sais clairement que c'est
c'est pas assez moi ma couleur passe
quelque chose de très propre comme on
dit très sympa que c'est pas ça j'aime
que ce soit très produit mais mais dans
la couleur je sais que c'est une couleur
que j'entends beaucoup en ce moment et
je me méfie de ça j'aime bien qu'ils
aient gardé que juste de ça que même si
c'est de l'électro qui est ce petit côté
un peu punk d'une manière ou d'une autre
à cette petite tache donc on n'arrive
pas à effacer
et donc voilà mais oui oui si je pense
que c'est juste c'est seulement le début
de ces explorations j'ai vraiment envie
d'aller beaucoup plus loin
et d'ailleurs je pense que fin je sais
déjà que j'ai continué à travailler avec
jérémie on a des trucs sur le flou je
voudrais qu'on termine sur
une notion c'est votre premier album
vous avez fait grâce au crowdfunding
ouais vous avez vraiment un soutien de
vos spectateurs
ouais ce film c'est un spectateur
auditeur dieter parce que ça serait plus
la télé est bon je suis pas trop passer
ces derniers temps mais mais ouais ils
sont hyper bon autour de pardon d'abord
un engouement alors qu'il ne connaissait
même pas l'album parce que ouais ouais
ouais non ça c'était c'est vrai que
c'était ça je n'aurais rien donné bon
alors j'ai fait quand même un mini
concert à appareil à un an également
entendre qu'ils avaient déjà les débuts
dont s'est laissée il y avait aussi six
qu'il y'avait j'ai pleuré
donc bon il y avait moyen peu d'entendre
des choses mais c'est vrai que quand
j'ai annoncé que j'ai lancé la campagne
j'ai rien mis en écoute j'ai n'ai mis
que après après les vingt mille euros
c'est parce que c'était le genre avait
dit d'elle je faisais écouter et
effectivement ouais ça m'a ça m'a
beaucoup touché
je pense que que c'est le fait que je
sois en inde et qui a clairement
beaucoup joué c'est le fait que je n'ai
pas débarqué du jour au lendemain un
belge avait déjà fait un album en inde
et en anglais
qui était un tournant pas évident par
rapport à mon public et qui sait
pourtant très bien passé donc du coup je
pense que yahoo d'un mois une certaine
confiance qui est que même si peut-être
qu'ils amoureusement pas en tout cas
artistiquement il ya et je pense qu'il
faut en tout cas ils me suivent
et est ce que j'aime bien c'est que
comment ils respectent vachement le fait
que c'est en tout cas j'essaie toujours
de faire plus ou moins différents et que
et que ça fait partie du risque que
peut-être là ça leur paiera pas mais
mais en tout cas ils respectent la
démarche quoi et donc ça ça m'a beaucoup
touché puis à des gens qui m'ont
clairement dit ah bah ouais non mais moi
le fait que tu sois regarder franchement
tu vois mademoiselle k way je sais pas
si j'aurais donné comme ça mais là tu
sois en inde et mais je te soutiens à
fond
ouais j'ai vraiment des gens qui me
faisait ça donc ses limites il de ces il
donnait plus pour pour une cause en fait
la cause indique que que le fond que en
fait il s'en foutait l hemi de laquelle
chanson j'allais sortir ce qui était
important c'est le principe que tu
sortes à mon album inde et ça je pense
que c'est non négligeable dans le dans
le succès qui a eu cette campagne et
voilà et donc ça me touche à fond et je
les remercie encore j'ai beaucoup
remercier mais bon je continue à les
remercier à l'occasion merci
mademoiselle k d'autres événements
reporter le spectacle de gaspard proust
qui devait avoir lieu mardi dernier la
nouvelle date est connue rendez vous au
prisme le 31 mai prochain
c'est la fin de cette culture je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mercredi prochain
[Musique]
à